[Music]
one of the most remarkable landmarks
near Dallas is of course AT&T Stadium
it's home to the Dallas Cowboys starting
this weekend it will be hosting the NCAA
Final Four
so all this week to honor the Final Four
taking place here in Texas we're doing
what anyone would do we're shooting full
court baskets outside AT&T stadium with
the help of a catapult we stole from
Mark Cuban's bedroom it's a full court
3-point shot now instead of using a
basketball that's boring we're launching
something uniquely Texan every night so
tonight it's the 72-ounce steak from the
big texan in amarillo that's what we'll
be launching that's right an animal died
for this joke here we go four three two
[Applause]
so close you think we give up that's not
what you do in Texas you try again no
you in reloaded the stake
for three
I'm gonna eat that steak tonight ladies
and gentlemen here's the coolest part we
teamed up again with AT&T to bring you
our new conan 360 camera it's
revolutionary technology allowing our
viewers to watch all those catapult
shots in 360-degree video right on their
computer tablet or phone so let's take a
look at the conan 360 replay where you
get to see all the action from every
angle and you can really experience this
breakthrough technology so thanks for
our friends at AT&T for bringing you
kota 360 now you'll be able to
experience our show in a whole new way
all the stupidity in 360